france cette décision en appel
aujourd'hui pour rudesse il est la
banque suisse et soupçonnés d'avoir
illégalement démarcher des clients
français entre 2004 et 2012 pour les
soustraire au fisc
ubs a été condamné à une amende record
en première instance et le jugement est
donc attendu aujourd'hui à la mi-journée
pour plus de précision va retrouver tout
de suite notre reporter katia technique
[Musique]
bonjour katia alors expliquez nous sur
quoi va se prononcer la cour d'appel
aujourd'hui
et bien sûr le cas de cette banque
suisse ubs une affaire qui avait défrayé
la chronique
un véritable scandale à d'évasion
fiscale il ya eu de scandale ubs dans le
monde en tout cas en france et bien les
ressorts avait été dévoilée par des
lanceurs dallaire tels que stéphanie à
gibbons ou nicolas forissier la plus
grande banque de gestion de fortune au
monde avait été condamné en première
instance à payer 3,7 milliards d'euros
une amende record et donc comme vous le
disiez elle avait été accusée entre 2004
et 2012 de démarcher des clients
français sa s'est autorisée mais sur le
sol français ce qui est strictement
illégal et d'avoir ouvert des comptes
non déclarés
et puis il leur aurait suggéré
subtilement divers mécanismes d'évasion
fiscale et ensuite ubs aurait créé un
système de paiement de bonus au culte
pour les chargés d'affaires qui
s'appelle les carnets adulé des fichiers
excel sur lesquels étaient notés ces
primes alors pour tout cela la banque
avait été condamné pour blanchiment
aggravé de fraude fiscale et démarchage
bancaire illégal ces cadres six cadres
avaient été condamnés à des amendes
également et des peines de prison avec
sursis mais la banque ubs avait fait
appel arguant qu'elle n'avait jamais
franchi la ligne rouge qu'elle avait que
fait que respecter la législation en
vigueur à l'époque le parquet cette fois
ci pour le deuxième procès avait requis
2 milliards d' euros d'amande au moins
alors c'est moins qu'en première
instance pourquoi parce que la loi a
changé entre ces deux procès est
aujourd'hui la vente doit être calculée
sur la base des impôts non perçus et non
pas sur le montant faramineux des
comptes qui étaient à dissimuler alors
c'est une aubaine pour ubs mais même si
la demande est moins lourde eh bien il
ya quand même une raison de se réjouir
car depuis bien le secret bancaire a été
levée et donc fin 2015 4000 clients du
bs avaient déclaré leur compte ils sont
aujourd'hui quinze mille en tout 20 au
niveau des banques suisses et les
banques sont obligées de communiquer les
infos dont elle dispose c'est une chose
qui a fait parfois défaut au procès
parce que c'était encore couvertes par
le secret bancaire en tout cas la
décision est attendue aujourd'hui à
13h30 merci beaucoup catia pour toutes
ces précisions un katia technique on va
suivre évidemment ce procès en appel
aujourd'hui